The white fragility of weirdos
propagating the lie
that immigrants are to blame for the housing shortage
is repugnant. If you don't know me,
my name is Raven, and as a black Jew,
I understand scapegoating when I see it.
Here's the formula. Instead of naming what the actual problem is,
which is a lack of affordable housing,
the scapegoat is always to blame.
In this case, the scapegoat is folks were immigrants.
Black folks are always a scapegoat for crime,
and therefore that makes it permissible to overpolice our communities.
Similarly,
Jewish folks became the scapegoats during 1930s and 40s Germany
for the economic woes of the nation,
and therefore we had to be mass annihilated.
Is it starting to click?
The thing that strikes me about white supremacy
is how fundamentally unimaginative it is
to regurgitate the same methodology of hatred
over and over again. It's really quite pitiful.
I almost feel bad for people who operate this way. Almost.